[Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  ladies and gentlemen five time world  champion has returned to Staples Center  number eight and number 24 Kobe Bryant  [Music]  lebron james last night in phoenix just  reporters of 119 exclusive than in  transition  [Music]  [Applause]  coos why not  gets the block and one in on Harris  brilliant struggled burning [ __ ] up hot  Scouter here comes Joe  [Applause]  [Laughter]  involved  I've seen everybody miss that blow you  just say you got a painting of you going  up on the side of a building in  Indianapolis aside LeBron change of the  mind century pants it came from one soul  ball previous played and Williams and  backdoor cut Jonathan Williams face  don't cancel to go mr. rookie a lot of  chili James  [Applause]  this year from downtown  [Applause]  51% sir inside they go in a beautiful  slice by Malik Beasley  [Applause]  [Music]  James inside  [Applause]